let's kick things off with a mini theory
you know every jurassic park movie
features dinosaurs chasing humans all
over the place looking for a snack yeah
probably wouldn't happen especially when
you're talking about the big boys like
the t-rex you see t-rexes are apex
predators that need a daily caloric
intake of 200 000 calories the average
human body contains a little over 125
000 calories which is pretty darn close
to that 200k daily limit so at first
that would make it seem like humans are
the perfect high efficiency snack the
power bar pick me up for a dinosaur
except there's one problem with that the
human is gonna run away animals are
primed to find the most efficient
sources of food and considering that an
adult t-rex topped out somewhere between
15 and 25 miles per hour while they run
or 24 to 40 kilometers an hour any human
with a halfway decent car is gonna be
able to get away
slow down a little i don't think so no
jeff goldblum you you can listen to her
you don't got to go that fast must go
faster and that's not even mentioning
our ability to hide in small spaces a
massive six-ton t-rex being forced to
hunt down a fleeing or hiding human
would be hemorrhaging massive amounts of
energy suddenly that high-efficiency
snack has turned into a high-efficiency
workout and if you're gonna be spending
those calories and hunting the payoff is
gonna need to be much bigger for proof
of this just look at other apex
predators in the wild today both lions
and wolves can go for almost a week or
two without food before finally getting
themselves a good catch at which point
they end up eating up to a fourth of
their body weight in one sitting believe
it or not some crocodiles can go for a
year without a meal before they end up
chomping down on half their body weight
that pattern holds for many large modern
day predators with these animals getting
weeks or months worth of calories all in
one sitting these are feast and famine
animals if they're going hard after a
meal well it's gotta be a big one a
human just wouldn't fill that need for a
t-rex why go after a puny human when
there's a chunky stegosaurus that can
give you more food that's easier to take
down it makes scenes like this one in
the movie where a t-rex leaves a big
kill it's already eating to go run after
some humans that are a fraction of the
caloric value absolutely ridiculous no
wonder the spinosaurus kills the t-rex
in the end it was the far smarter animal
welcome
to thoracic pop hello internet welcome
to film theory the show we're diving
into the lore of your favorite
franchises has been genetically inserted
into our dna so if you were a child
growing up in the 90s it's likely that
you saw jurassic park and fell in love
with it seriously this movie and its
various sequels created an entire
generation of dinosaur kids except uh
you know
there's one problem with that what's
attacking the humans throughout the
series yeah they aren't dinosaurs that
first park was legit they didn't need
these genetic hybrids they just needed
dinosaurs real dinosaurs actually
forgettable side character that's not
what i meant even before they started
mixing and matching jeans in the reboot
trilogy they weren't real dinosaurs
they've never been real dinosaurs that's
probably a good thing because if they
were well jurassic park would be about
as dangerous as an aquarium it would
yield one really boring movie so today
we're gonna be building our own
theorasic park to show you why a park
made of real dinosaurs is probably gonna
be the safest zoo ever don't believe me
let's go now this first part is
something i bet a lot of you already
know see despite the original jurassic
park really shaping a lot of how modern
pop culture views dinosaurs these aren't
real dinosaurs and i don't mean they're
animatronics or cgi or whatever what i
mean is that while it was impossible to
know what exactly dinosaurs looked like
it definitely wasn't anything like this
for the longest time all we had to go
off of to figure out how dinosaurs
looked like were their fossilized bones
which led to a great deal of artistic
liberty being taken with the imagery
that we now associate with them many
artists grossly underestimated the
amount of soft tissues like fat that
dinosaurs had because almost none of it
survived the process of fossilization so
their interpretations were actually way
skinnier than dinosaurs probably were
professional paleo artists or people who
create art of extinct creatures call
this misinterpretation shrink wrapping
just to give you an idea of how wildly
different dinosaurs might have looked in
2012 a group of paleo artists released a
book called all yesterdays featuring art
that imagined how modern animals would
look like if they were shrink-wrapped
the same way as dinosaurs like this
beauty right here what do you think that
thing is those sickle-like arms that
sinewy neck those terrifying claws it's
a swan just a swan but you immediately
get the idea of what they're talking
about here right jurassic park's art
direction used a lot of that
shrink-wrapping technique giving us a
heavily skewed perception of what these
things would have actually looked like
they also gave all the dinosaurs scaly
reptilian skin however over the past
three decades paleontologists have
concluded that while many dinosaurs were
scaly some of the really iconic ones
like the velociraptor and t-rex were
most likely covered in feathers this was
proven with the discovery of fossils
like the archaeopteryx found in germany
in 2016. notice the feather indents all
around its wings that same year a 99
million year old piece of amber found in
myanmar was discovered to have preserved
an actual dinosaur feather sadly no dino
dna to extract and clone from that one
the filmmakers behind jurassic park
responded to the discoveries by politely
ignoring them and continuing to peddle
scientific lies look i get it i
understand why these conclusions were
reached well after the first jurassic
park came out when they had already
established an iconic look for their big
monsters they even had written in an
in-universe excuse because these
dinosaurs were spliced with frog dna
which could potentially explain the
difference in appearance and the fact
that our understanding of dinosaurs has
evolved since jurassic park has been
lampshaded by the more modern films like
here in jurassic park 3. what john
hammond an injen did at jurassic park
is create genetically engineered theme
park monsters nothing more and nothing
less and in jurassic world and if their
genetic code was pure many of them would
look quite different but you didn't ask
for reality you asked for more tea so
dinosaurs irl would clearly look
different but all this research got me
thinking what if we did ask for reality
if we were somehow able to clone
dinosaurs and completely recreate them
without any sort of genetic trickery
that the scientists use in the movie how
would they fare today what would we have
to do if we wanted to make a real film
theory approved jurassic park the
theorasic park if you will loyal
theorists let me tell ya the real
jurassic park wouldn't look anything
like we see in these movies wanna see it
well come along
first we're gonna have to specify what
exactly is gonna be in our thoracic park
see what we broadly consider to be the
dinosaur times actually covers hundreds
of millions of years which are grouped
into multiple geologic periods with cool
sounding names the jurassic period was
just one of those covering the massive
stretch of time between 201 million
years ago and
145 million years ago however most of
the big ticket dinosaurs that we'll want
in our park actually hail from the
cretaceous period which was much more
recent spanning from 145 million years
ago to 66 million years ago that
includes the t-rex the velociraptor
triceratops brontosaurus mosasaurus
parasaurolophus basically all the major
players from the movies i guess
cretaceous park didn't sound quite as
cool for the branding anyway because we
want reactions like this t-rex
you said you've got a t-rex uh-huh
so you can that's the period we're gonna
be examining but let me tell you
re-creating the conditions for these
animals to live comfortably isn't gonna
be as easy as picking out the right
tropical island for sale pretty much
everything about the environment was
completely different during the
cretaceous for instance the earth was
much hotter back then only the highest
latitude mountains show evidence of
glaciers and consistent year-long
snowfall the planet was so warm in fact
that dinosaur fossils have been found
just 15 degrees off the cretaceous south
pole which would be the equivalent today
of finding the t-rex chilling out with
penguins down in antarctica this is all
because the cretaceous earth was what's
called a greenhouse world the
concentration of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere was about one thousand to one
thousand four hundred parts per million
sometimes even reaching as high as two
thousand by contrast pre-industrial
revolution human civilization was
keeping co2 levels sitting at around 280
parts per million more recently it's
climbed up to about 409 even still the
world these dinosaurs lived in had an
atmosphere with between 2.5 to 5 times
more co2 than our own it might not sound
like that big of a deal but it is it
meant that global average temperatures
were about 9 to 18 degrees fahrenheit
hotter than they are today or 5 to 10
degrees celsius hotter additionally the
overall climate for the cretaceous was a
lot more consistent worldwide the
difference in temperature between the
equator and the poles could be as little
as half as what we experienced today
this means that dinosaurs were likely
mesothermic meaning that they were
somewhere between warm and cold-blooded
they had some ability to regulate their
body temperature but they didn't need to
because the earth's temperature was much
more stable tldr the dinosaurs at
thoracic park might find the modern
world a bit brisk for their tastes as
responsible zookeepers we're gonna have
to account for that but obviously a
higher amount of co2 in the atmosphere
is gonna change more than just the
temperature it's gonna affect how these
dinosaurs breathed scientists are
reasonably confident that dinosaurs
breathed oxygen and despite elevated co2
levels there was still plenty of it in
the atmosphere during the cretaceous
period but scientists can't agree on how
much oxygen there was by analyzing air
bubbles trapped in amber between 130 and
67 million years ago some studies have
shown that oxygen could have made up as
much as 30 to 35
the atmosphere other studies have that
number much lower comparing the makeup
of fossilized plant resin to modern day
plants to conclude that the atmospheric
oxygen levels could have been as low as
10 to 15 percent regardless both of
those numbers are actually very
different from the modern day oxygen
level of 21 and a swing that large in
either direction would be problematic
for any dinosaur trying to live in the
present you see if the cretaceous
atmosphere contained 30 to 35 oxygen
breathing modern air would be dizzying
for the dinosaurs you ever travel up a
mountain after spending a lot of time at
sea level if you have you'll know that
it's exhausting it can sometimes take
days for your body and brain to adjust
to the thinner levels of oxygen in the
air as you climb further and further
above sea level now think about a
dinosaur that lived by breathing air
that was over 35 oxygen over a third
well it would be like a person going
from sea level to a mountain that was 9
500 feet tall 2 900 meters it's
certainly not impossible to survive i
mean people have evolved to live in
elevated places like tibet life uh
finds a way but these dinosaurs would
likely have something similar to ongoing
altitude sickness suffering from nausea
dizziness and headaches all the time in
some serious cases altitude sickness can
cause a build-up of fluid in your lungs
that can be fatal on the other hand if
dinosaurs evolved breathing an
atmosphere that was just 10 to 15 oxygen
jumping up to modern day levels would
add 25 to 50 more oxygen than they were
used to at that point they have to worry
about the opposite problem oxygen
toxicity a condition that you get when
you breathe in too much extra oxygen
this can harm lung tissue cause parts of
your lungs to fill with fluid or cause
them to collapse in some serious and
severe cases it can even lead to death
basically bodies evolved to breathe very
specific mixtures of air and any
significant deviation from that mixture
isn't gonna be too great for the
dinosaurs in our park which again is
gonna present us with some very serious
problems but beyond just the survival of
our dinos something else that would be
lame about our park is that most of our
star attractions are gonna be asleep
during peak hours several
paleontologists have theorized that a
surprising number of dinosaurs were
actually nocturnal and we know this
because of a very specific type of
fossil as we've already discussed soft
tissues within and around the eye
basically never survive the process of
fossilization however sometimes the
scleral rings did these are bony rings
around the eye socket which help to
support the eyeballs of animals with
eyes that aren't spherical
paleontologists have been able to
determine the size and shape of dinosaur
eyes based exclusively on these rings
which in turn helps them to determine if
the eyes were built for daylight or low
light situations animals that operate
during the day they have plenty of light
to work with so their scleral rings tend
to be thicker nocturnal animals on the
other hand need to get as much light
into their eyes as possible meaning that
their scleral rings tend to be thinner
leaving a wide hole in the skull this
was most common in theropods including
one of the most popular dinosaurs the
velociraptor the fact that the lost
world actually used a great effect back
in 1997. anyway considering that dinos
like the velociraptor are going to be a
big draw for the park and i doubt that
any guests are going to want to be out
at 2 a.m to see small raptor chickens
well we're gonna need to do something
about simulating a reverse day night
cycle for some of these guys so for the
film theory approved jurassic park we're
actually dealing with a lot of issues
we're working with animals that are
living at elevated temperatures that
need to be consistent year round they're
used to a hot co2 rich atmosphere
they're used to a precise level of
oxygen that was either meaningfully
higher or lower than present day and
will want to be able to simulate
lighting conditions to reverse day and
night so people can actually see some
action sure sounds like a lot if we want
the dinosaurs to be happy and healthy
but i have a solution a theoretical
solution see a real world jurassic park
is possible if and only if all the dinos
live in giant terrariums oh there it is
yup just as lame as it sounds at our
hypothetical theoretic park each
terrarium could have artificially
managed levels of both oxygen and co2 it
would be much easier to control the
temperature inside each terrarium so the
dinosaurs are in environments that
they're comfortable with and within a
terrarium we could simulate a day night
cycle using blue light leds thereby
recreating day during night and vice
versa and you want to know the craziest
part of all of this a jurassic park
designed in this way with real dinosaurs
in mind would be so much safer than we
see in the movies the dinosaurs would be
in entirely isolated environments sure
we'd have to sacrifice the whole petting
zoo angle but not a single guest would
ever get close enough to hurt or be hurt
by a dinosaur and if there were ever to
be a breach in a terrarium and the
dinosaur escaped while the massively
different temperature and atmosphere
would daze the creature exhausting and
confusing it as it dealt with either
altitude sickness or oxygen toxicity in
turn that would make it easier to
recapture and return to the proper
habitat it's wild how much differently
the events of jurassic park would have
gone down if you know they had actually
cloned dinosaurs as opposed to creating
whatever weird genetic hybrids these
things are meant to
i'm not be the same mistakes again no
you're making you're making all new ones
no wonder no one wanted to invest in
this thing
after careful consideration i decided
not to endorse your park yeah cause
they're investing in mine but hey even
with the incredibly dangerous genetic
hybrids from jurassic park there was
still so much more that ingen could have
done to make their parks safer both for
the guests and for the dinosaurs if you
want to know what three simple fixes
could have saved jurassic park click the
video that you see on screen right here
or if you want to watch us uncover the
conspiracy that doom jurassic world from
the very start you can check out our
lore based video over here and hey if
you want more videos just like these you
should chomp down on that subscribe
button like a t-rex that hasn't eaten in
months and as always remember it's just
a theory a film theory and cuts